[Music]  what about you  sorry  if you could go anywhere in the whole  world where would you go  i always wanted to be part of something  bigger  i love that answer something that laughs  that means something something more  important than life yes  [Music]  it's written in the stars i am a star  if i had money i would only spend it on  things that were fun you know not boring  things like taxes i'm just waiting for  everyone to party  [Applause]  forever when i first moved to l.a signs  on all the doors said no actors and dogs  allowed i changed that  and now y'all ready for something  different  you know we have to do  we have to redefine the form  map those dreams and print them into  history look up and say  eureka i'm not alone  get it  i'm in so much trouble manny  we have to live now  what i do means something  you thought this town needed you  it's bigger than you  it's the most magical place in the world  [Applause]  who wants to see me fight a snake  hell yeah  [Music]  you